The first way we prevent over fitting
is by looking at the performance under
validation set, and stopping to
train as soon as we stop improving.
It's called early termination, and
it's still the best way to prevent your
network from over-optimizing
on the training set.
Another way is to apply regularization.
Regularizing means applying artificial
constraints on your network
that implicitly reduce
the number of free parameters
while not making it more
difficult to optimize.
In the skinny jeans analogy,
think stretch pants.
They fit just as well, but
because they're flexible,
they don't make things harder to fit in.
The stretch pants of
are called L2 Regularization.
The idea is to add another term to
the loss, which penalizes large weights.
It's typically achieved by adding the L2
norm of your weights to the loss,
multiplied by a small constant.
And yes, yet another hyper-perimeter.
Sorry about that.